so Jim Austin came to us actually he got
I think dragged into one of our other
lectures by a previous speaker karen
marcello from Dork bhatt and survival
research labs and he brought in these
objects and and they were tremendously
compelling objects and then I realized
that they were things like you know
whole sets of things and it looks like
just someone you know some crazy persons
chainring until he explains to you that
oh this is the piece of metal that it
starts with in order to get this very
finely crafted thing and and there's
very few people that that work in this
medium especially to the degree that Jim
does and we thought it would be really
great to share with you all both the
process by which he got there and then
the process by which he's now doing
things in the world so the you were
talking to a fair extent tonight about
the Iron Age and just to put it in
context of long now you know many of you
have seen this chart and the idea of
long now is that we are we're talking
about the last ten thousand years in the
next ten thousand years and that we are
not at the end of a ten thousand year
story but really in the middle of at
least a twenty thousand year story of
modern humanity and and the age that we
are talking about tonight is really a
big part of that and you know as you can
see from you know 8,000 BC ten thousand
years ago this is when the Mesolithic
Age started and then the Neolithic
around the same time that the first
cities and then there was this really
big fluorescing time that happened
around 2500 you can see things like
Stonehenge and the pyramids as well as
the Bronze Age really got going then and
then the Iron Age started you know
there's iron definitely being used long
before that and even steel long before
that but around 800 BC and we are still
in the Iron Age and you know we're even
still in the Bronze Age we're still in
the wood age these ages don't end they
are Continuum's but there's certainly
skills that have been learned and had
peak knowledge and Damascus steel let's
say
or even some of the things like making
anvils which we'll hear about tonight
which are actually arts that have
largely been completely lost to the
world and are now done in ways that are
inferior to the old way and there's just
no real model for them to be done now
and so we're going to talk about some of
those and you know some of the some of
the techniques that we're talking about
tonight are still used in highly modern
manufacture I mean jet planes still have
forged elements and mostly now and in
some of the high-tech industries we use
forging and we even use it in the clock
project the 10,000 year clock you can
see these stainless ring forgings these
are basically when you want to get if
you were gonna try and make a sort of
large circular thing out of stainless
steel now making it all a disc cutting
it out of plate would cost way too much
money so you actually get these ring
forgings made you machine those and then
you so you get this what's called
near-net objects made and so we did that
for some of the largest bearings that
are in the clock these a whole series of
30-inch bearings that were that we built
for the clock and so it's a it's both an
ancient process and it's an extremely
modern process at the same time and I
think the other thing that's important
to understand about about forging is
it's it's very different than most of
the modern processes that we now have it
used to be for the last kind of hundred
years we've really been using reductive
processes which means you have a milling
machine moving through steel or metal
that's removing from a large block and
so you're doing reductive process and
now everyone's very excited about
additive processes where we're we're
adding layers of plastic or even metal
now to create things with 3d printers
and and that's that's what that is but
what we're talking about tonight is
really what's called effectively a
plastic process yes where we start with
a lump of a thing and you don't really
get to change its mass fundamentally you
just get to move its mass around and so
you actually have to your brain has to
think in a very different way to create
things with four
then it does for some of these other
processes and it's you know I think many
of you have heard the old adage you know
how did you know Michelangelo how did
you carve that you know the Pieta out of
stone he's like well I I started with
the stone and I removed everything that
wasn't the Pieta right and so that's
that's one way of thinking about how to
create objects but this way is is I
started with this mass of stone and I
pushed it or clay in a way it's more
like clay I formed it into that object
but I never got to change its mass
fundamentally so that's what we're gonna
talk tonight and I want to start just
certain extent just on your on how you
got here
and can you say a little bit about how
you found forging or how it found you
yes well I was raised to be something a
little bit above an engineer which in my
family meant I was gonna be a scientist
my dad was an engineer and the pressure
in the 60s 50 is whatever was to you
know to get a higher degree and I
started going school to be a chemist and
I kept plugging away at that somehow
nobody noticed though that what I really
wanted to be was an archaeologist and it
just basically came back to bite me
halfway through my PhD work at Berkeley
in 1982 I just couldn't do it anymore I
realized it was never gonna be a great
scientist and I always wanted to make
something with my hands so I decided
basically to pursue a traditional craft
and about the same time I got the
opportunity to travel to Germany to see
if there would be an apprenticeship
available to me and I took the
opportunity and somehow it worked I
ended up there a few months later and at
the end of 1982 as an apprentice in
Bavaria and we have your your final
project right for one of them yes this
would be possibly considered something
like a master's piece in in the 1980s in
Germany although I never became a man
I wanted to do something in my trade
which was lock making which would be
equivalent to it something like my boss
made and this is what I came up with
it's a lock
based on 15th century mid 15th century
German locks detailed a little bit
industrially and the isn't there there's
a history of lock making and forging
didn't I mean forging came out of lock
Ming or there was some guild association
is that right actually there was a guild
division yeah sort of as was typical in
Germany and the Middle Ages that the
guilds kind of rigidly defined what
their sphere of influence was and
interestingly enough a lock maker was
allowed to use a file Andy blacksmith
was not so and that's that and that's a
it's a curious division it gets back to
the thing that I was mentioning before
reductive versus plastic or or additive
and and so a lot of your processes
especially as we get to the Viking axis
as well as this you do a forging to get
it very close to what you want and then
you do a lot of very very careful file
work or grinding work to get it to the
final thing but yeah I mean when you
have a chance you should come up here
and look at this maze key the first part
they made the key and feel the action of
this thing I mean it is and each gate
that's within the key is stunning and it
just hurts my teeth to think someone
filed this this beautifully actually the
the challenge was to forge the parts
then finish them only with files and
with the aid of a straightedge vernier
caliper and a one or two other measuring
tools but nothing else and I finally
broke down at the end of the process
after I'd spent about a year of my free
time on it and I I turned the rivets on
a lathe I kind of always I kind of
always regret that now
and what would have been the process
without turning monoglia forging them
closely and then filing yeah quite
possibly it's it's not unlikely that
they had some setup to file them on a
lathe or something like turning yeah
some kind of hand turning yeah and the
and you know you use traditional methods
not necessarily 100% traditional tools
as we know things like power hammers are
in part of your relative our welding
machines and and and electric grinders
but what how did you end up getting into
some of these traditional crafts are
trying to find ways that that that these
objects were originally made what was
attractive to you about that well to
begin with the objects themselves were
incredibly attractive to me I you could
see hints of forging processes that were
used that which were partly mysterious
because you know they sort of self
extinguished the marks but what you
could see was always kind of enticing
like to figure out how they might have
done that and eventually that just
became a really driving force for me
toward the end of my stay in Germany in
1987-88 I was simply looking for old
rural objects which were made with very
simple means but a great deal of skill
and you know things that might be
considered a trick unless he simply
learned it from the guy who was making
them already and trying to figure its
reverse-engineer that stuff so that's
what a lot of the key rings are about
yeah these key rings that kind of show
you the process right the trick and and
one of those is this one which you want
to talk about that how you how you got
to figure out this particular trick well
I've always been interested in axes and
this is this isn't the ax that I wanted
to forge in the in the 80s I wanted to
do a goose wing axe but that's a little
still a little beyond me right now but I
did get very interested in the Viking
Age by my friend Jeff Pringle who's here
and
you know the Vikings are kind of known
for axes for various reasons and yeah
like it's the last thing a lot of people
saw and anyways it was also a few things
were known but apparently not very
uniformly by people who were interested
in axes one it was known you know it's
it's always it's long been known that
the axe was welded together to form the
eye it wasn't there wasn't any form of
hole cutting that led to this hole it
was actually forged in a kind of a
special sequence of steps and then
folded over to form the eye and then
these two laps pieces of metal which
come close together are basically
laminated together and forged such that
you can't see the joint in most axes and
that to me was like again it was the
great attraction of figuring out how
that would happen and that was not
something that was kind of widely known
you had to figure that out by by looking
at old pieces and and working it out
well Jeff helped out a lot on that and
it was known to academia it was known
that you know this was a way of doing it
but academia is like shockingly
uncurious about like how that might
actually work and a lot of people who a
lot of people who taught themselves axe
making let's say sort of followed the
pattern of making a hammer which in a
modern sense means you punch a hole in
it so they assumed especially in the
case of some very beautiful axes of
course they put the nicest ones out in
the museum's where you can't necessarily
tell how they're made and so there
wouldn't be evidence of a weld and a lot
of people sort of skipped right over to
the the idea that they have be punched
and I just thought well that seems so
unlikely for a lot of material specific
reason they didn't really have a chisel
that could cut a deep hole and hot hot
metal back then and and then when it the
idea of lap welding the I came up I just
I just had to try it you know I tried
about ten different ways that didn't
work
very well and finally came up with this
method and a series of measurements and
steps to produce it and so and when you
say welding we actually have we have a
good video of Forge welding okay so
those guys that were with the big ring
that was is that one on yes that we
should put on the forge welding one
because I think you know often when you
think of welding now you think of arc
welding by pumping a ton of amperage
into into something and heating it up
locally what you're talking about is you
actually you put the whole thing get it
very very hot yes and Hammer it together
and weld it yeah yeah there's it's a
kind of mysterious process especially to
people who know a little bit of smithing
but they don't add a forged weld it
seems like the it's it's the ultimate
goal to learn how to do this and it's
quite doable
these guys are I mean just so they're
building a fire on the area they're
actually bringing the fire to the object
in this large case the guy hammering in
the background he's way in the
background yeah the fire is where the
weld the weldment is placed and it's
just heaped with coal and simply heat it
up slowly and carefully until the entire
piece top and bottom comes to a welding
each which you recognize as like looking
like a hundred watt light bulb I mean
it's just so bright you can't really see
it and it looks liquid on the surface
because any slag that's present is in
fact liquid which is protects the two
surfaces that have to come together and
it's basically the metallic you know
surfaces which are free of Aqsa of solid
oxides due to the liquid coating simply
approach each other so closely that the
that the metallic bonds form across the
joint and you've got basically one chunk
of metal
after that quite fascinating because you
you then you have to kind of plastically
deform both parts of the weld into each
other and finish the weld it's not you
don't bring two pieces together and run
a seam down them right should be vastly
less strong and they just have no way of
even doing localized right there was no
such and so it's actually a good segue
into this object
here right this is this is a an anvil
that was made in a way with this kind of
process right yes yes this is anvil
companies existed in Germany in the
Westphalia area and it was blessed with
iron ore and water power and coal so and
basically that's that's what you need to
make large things out of iron which
would be things like anvils and anchors
stuff like that so it turns out that
anvils to my surprise I actually
realized in Germany that I had no idea
how an anvil was made so I went to my
boss in Germany and said so how you know
this is a German anvil how was it made
and he had no idea and it became clear
very shortly that nobody had really
taken the time to learn about it they
just weren't interested it wasn't gonna
make you any money so anyways after
continued asking I finally found
somebody who was obsessed by handles he
had them in a something in a shed in the
garden and they were just sitting there
were sitting in a pit stacked and he
knew a lot about it and he got me in
touch with it the last anvil making
company they had in fact bought all the
tools and materials of all the other
companies that slowly went out of
business in the early 20th century and
basically the factory was there the
tools were there the materials were
there there just weren't enough people
to still make them and but they
reconditioned but there was like not
actually enough people it wasn't that
there was a low number of people but you
didn't you need like eight people
swinging hammers at the same time in
order to do it to make like a big anvil
yeah but you could make an anvil with
three people and there was two so
basically it could have been a cover
story because they just didn't want to
make them anymore
they probably couldn't profitably do it
or it could have been you know probably
true that you needed I don't know what
the three guys exactly would you - one
guy would have to bring part of the
anvil from one fire the other guy would
have to bring the part the animal from
the other fire and probably
the other guy laid the first
sledgehammer blows and the other guy's
probably dropped the tongs or whatever
and grabbed their they're striking
hammers and finished so but and that's
how you added each piece the the anvil
was simply built up from one made chunk
and each piece was added to it and this
anvil which is called the old Bavarian
form was sort of the bugbear it was the
hardest animal to make it was the one
with the most pieces there are probably
fifteen or sixteen pieces of metal in
this anvil the most important one was
the hard steel face which generally went
from tip to tip but the horns were all
added on the the breast was added on
this defeat were added everything which
came separately always in each case a
small piece of metal was brought to the
the large piece both a welding heat and
they were simply hammered together and
beyond that they were sort of smeared
into each other and sometimes little
little bits they called sausages in
Germany of course or they were called
glutes in English and they were simply
added to fare the curves together that
the Germans were were awfully good at
doing this and taking everybody else's
business away basically because they
made them for all the other countries of
Europe too and so I mean I think what's
interesting is that we often see anvils
and we go oh it's an anvil but what's
always unclear I think is that the anvil
was a was an amazing piece of technology
right it was the thing that you could
hit all the other metal against and it
didn't move and it didn't get formed the
way the thing that you are that is
red-hot that you're forming and that it
came in there's hundreds of different
styles that you used to be able to order
them and you I think there were some
shots of the cattle at the old catalogs
of anvils and each one of them had a
history and they were even regionalised
right there was like yeah it was the one
place that made one and another one and
yeah they wanted different shapes every
in a region there was every different
trade that needed an anvil there was
every different region all over each
country and you know I mean a different
anvil might have I had the hole over
here or whatever but there were a lot of
different styles of making them and
these involves and
well and you even brought so you brought
a lot of this stuff back from Germany
after your tenure there right yeah but
include some of the animals and I think
even the stumps that the anvils were yes
attached to yeah yeah there there just
happened to be a saw works about on the
top of my street and you know they had a
stack of oak tree trunks there and it
was easy to just drop off a couple of
handle bases and at the time I was going
to ship nine crates anyway so I just
threw them in the crates and they came
over with the anvils and I the other
tool that I think is interesting I think
a lot of people associate forging with
and we've seen some videos of people
swinging hammers as well as yourself but
there's there's another modern version
of that that I think is worth talking
about you don't you don't swing in a
hammer for every single thing that you
form in a forge right no used power
hammer how are you yes sir power power
hammer is where I was going yes yes
not the water-powered hammer of a
thousand years ago rest they be
electrically powered hammer they they
used water power to power hammers that
would have been driven off line shaft in
the 30s it was a big obviously there's a
big push in the thirties to revamp the
industries of a lot of different
countries over there and that's when a
lot of things were converted from actual
shafts like in and now it's Swedish the
Olaf oars factory they were converted
from actual wooden hammers with big
medieval parts on them to the modern the
modern versions of hammers that were
designed about the beginning of the 20th
century right so this is a picture of
you operating your power hammer so a lot
of the work that you do is actually use
a foot pedal - yeah it's not striking
it's not cheating to get the striking
force against what you're after but you
you're kind of feathering that and that
becomes yes the art as well a good
hammer is highly controllable you could
you know you could Forge down three inch
square stock maybe and then and then
turn around forge out some quarter inch
square on the same hammer so it had the
sensitivity for the I think we have a
video of a water hammer being operated
in someone yeah by in an extremely
unlikely totally white suit
[Laughter]
and I'm gonna tell them you you're
working in a forge in a white outfit
yeah so this is this is the water hammer
give you an idea of the old way of
cheating it's away so you've mentioned a
little bit about how you got to to
Viking things was there just something
about the genre or was there how did you
end up in the Viking world well it's a
kind of attractive
level of technology to work out it the
tools are small so if you're going to
teach people how to do this work they
they don't have to find a 400 pound
anvil to do it with they could do it on
a little tiny handle because basically
that's what they used back then the
selection of tools was it was basic it
wasn't highly sophisticated so you don't
you don't know if I have a giant tool
selection and and yet the skill was the
skill was there and it so it kind of
throws the emphasis on the skills and I
just find it a useful arena to teach and
learn in and that we've talked a little
bit about both iron and steel can you I
think I'm not sure that everybody
understands the difference in why you
would want to make something out of one
thing or another and I know there's a
there's a special step also in the axe
making that that maybe this piece kind
of exemplifies well this axe has been
brought to the stage where a steel bit
that's a high carbon bit has been placed
in the front of the axe and the back of
the axe is made out of mild steel which
in my case is a proxy for bloomery iron
and that would have been a very low
carbon easy to forge metal it was the
cheapest form of iron but I you know
that said iron was a very expensive
commodity back then it had to be made by
you know back-breaking work you know
charcoal making or digging stacked
building it was and then when the iron
that you got looked like lava rocks
basically so those needed to be put
through a lot of additional steps to get
anything usable then you started making
axé so and so iron is is the is is what
you smelt out of the earth and steel is
steel would go through additional
refinement you might be able to smelt it
directly but you might also you know
take a more sure route to making steel
by taking some of your iron and maybe
making it into strips and then packing
those in charcoal and heating them up
too it's a yellow heat for six hours or
something like that in which case the
carbon simply diffuses it directly
diffuses into the iron and ups the
carbon content to maybe 0.8 or 1% carbon
you end up with something that's got the
potential to be a really fine steel at
that point though it's just it's like
cookie dough it doesn't have any good
consistency it takes a lot of refinement
to get a good blade steel or edge steel
out of that or something to put on your
hammer to take the impact so what you've
done is you've taken already expensive
iron you've decimated about 30% of its
weight maybe making it into steel and
then you have something that's much
harder to work with so right it's good
for blades it's good for blade but it
would be a lot more expensive and a lot
harder to form into any more of the more
complex shape and so they would not use
it for everything they would just use it
for the sharp bits yeah yeah and that
and you see that in the ancient
artifacts as well that kind of that line
you know as some of the better pieces
were probably made this way the problem
with artifacts is you don't know how
much it was used up you know reground or
whatever so you don't always know what
you're looking at there's the the actual
placement of steel or even the use of
steel is is a little harder to track
down then it would be in you know 19th
century work right yeah but yeah you
know in a good piece you'd see the steel
added to the front sometimes to decide
sometimes the middle you use I assume
you use commodity materials at this
point yeah how does this kind of compare
to some of the things that they would
have had and so the viking era
we're talking about kind of 880 right
say 800 to a thousand kind of time yeah
yes when they were making their best
stuff yeah yeah of course the guy is
just before they were called Vikings
we're making roughly similar stuff and
they Viking forms continued into the
Middle Ages slowly changed the material
didn't really change and the bloomery
iron was the the rule basically back
then it was very like a say a very low
carbon very soft because it wasn't it it
wasn't solid steel it had slag
interspersed throughout the throughout
the structure of iron so it tended to
move easily and it would have been
easier to weld together probably so what
I use is harder to forge it's harder to
weld together to a certain degree but
it's dead cheap and if you're going to
teach something to students then you
want to make a doable task out of all of
this stuff so I I teach in something
that you can buy and and I use
techniques and enable it just to weld
together well so that that doesn't
become a hurdle a lot of people are a
bit apt to think that you just can't
weld a modern steel together and just
like I wanted to show people that these
hammers aren't split I do want to show
people this is all doable technology and
so that's actually a great segue I want
to talk a bit about now how you're
conveying this to to the world now that
you've kind of figured out a lot of
these these things so you teach classes
in your own shop or at other places yep
my Danish friend thought up the name rot
Academy these cards are out there
Morton great guy and so that's mostly a
gear shop yes there is no other there's
no weather location I teach at the
crucible from time to time they've got
good stuff going on down there too
and but I wanted to have complete
control of the the tooling and the fires
and you know set the space up the way I
wanted to do it so the obviou obviously
to do is to devote part of my shop to
that purpose so I have six teaching
stations basically and this is over in
Oakland in Oakland yes and so
and part of that is is this process that
I'm holding up these two objects of and
both the kind of how you've brought
these objects to these kind of stop
motion states and I mean I think it's
worth pointing out the difficulty of
what he has done here they you know this
means that forever doing the whole
progression of let's say the acts making
he had to make that acts effectively 20
times or up to that stage 20 times in
order to to get to this thing so I I
highly encourage you in the end here is
to really look at these things they're
they're pretty amazing and and then
you've gone to another stage with this
much lighter version yes by 3d scanning
it and then putting these objects up so
that people can look at the 3d objects
as well as 3d printing them as another
way of conveying them and that's and
it's starting to get to where we are
here with the manual for civilization so
the the book the library shelves here
the idea is that this would hopefully be
the 3000 books you would most want to
restart civilization and certainly one
of the types of things we want are
things like how you do forging and one
of the very first things we brought in
here where the gingery series of books
that start with how to build a forge and
then once you build a forward you build
all these other things but fundamentally
the very first thing you need to make
before you make any other technology is
the forge itself and then those first
tools so it's I think one of our
attractions to this process is is that
it is it's it's the technology by which
all other technologies are bootstrapped
and so if you learn this one you then
can use it to make the tools that make
the tools that make the tools and so and
you do make some of your own tools we
you know things like hammers and I was
struck by how many different types of
hammers you have this is nothing
can you talk a little bit about making
your own tools to make to then make your
objects well it's it's something if you
go into smithing I'd by no means I
recommend doing that if you go into
smithing you're going to have to make a
lot of tools because there's not a lot
available and in some tools it's crucial
that it be made to your exact
specification like a Tong tongs if they
don't fit your work very very well don't
enable you to hold on to your work if
you can't control your iron you can't
Forge it so in some cases you're simply
going to have to make your own tongs
making hammers is somewhat the same
although it's it's also a matter of just
pride sometimes in using your own wares
there's always special bending tools or
whatever there's hundreds and hundreds
of tools you might end up making if you
Smith for 10 or 20 years and and the
tongs are really interesting to me in
machining one of the things that we
often do is make what are called soft
jaws where you machine the negative
shape of the thing of the complex shape
that you then want to hold in order to
do the reductive process of machining
further on it it's like when you flip
over your complicated machining thing
and now you have to hold on to it so one
of the most difficult things in
machining is is holding on to things and
I I think it's an interesting parallel
that that in forging you end up making
all these specialized tongs just to
solve one problem and so and this this
is kind of a different way of solving
the Tong prob data is cheating yes yes
this is it's used it so you did modern
TIG welding right yeah TIG welding where
you you basically you welded the the
Tong handle part of the deal right so
but one of the things you could have
done what they did is they built a a
ridiculous special Tong for every stage
of this process right I don't I don't
think you can do most of the work on the
back if you can simply grab the
thickness on the front and it could be
that they use a longer bar although the
the bar transmits heat and does become a
problem but yeah they probably just in
Sweden the guy who forged an axe for me
simply had one Tong for the front and
then he had a Tong for the back so it's
you can get by
with with if you make a bunch of similar
axes with maybe just a couple of tongs
and yeah actually we should talk a
little bit that you just went you just
went on a whirlwind tour of Scandinavia
yeah to meet some of all some of the
people that are there and you have kind
of supported what you do largely through
doing education here there's obviously
no state support for Viking axe foraging
in California but you went to the place
where that is different right yes yes
there okay so what I did in April I went
to Norway I spent about three weeks
there and it's been about a week in
Sweden yeah with the express purpose of
a teaching axe making Viking axe making
in Norway haha which worked it works and
I went to learn from four people who I
met through Facebook yeah and and two of
them turned out to be gold mines of
information and the other two guys were
great to hang out with and learn with -
I mean I learned something from
everybody one guy in particular Mattias
was a total gold mine and really fun to
hang out with this was one of yeah yeah
this is a acts that Matthias made form
for oh I ended up buying for it although
I have not paid for it yet but I keep
asking them it send me a PayPal invoice
but anyways he he made this axe he makes
axes along these lines he makes kind of
whatever he wants he he he lives in an
area western Sweden that's very
old-fashioned in a way they and there's
just tons of antiques and stuff around
there I mean there's like really old
stuff that you can like find at the
junkyard farm rolls I'll give it to you
or you get at the flea market whatever
in other words there's a there's a lot
of old stock that you can learn from
over there and that's what he does he he
gets this old stuff a lot of these
techniques have been to a certain extent
maintained and even taught at certain
schools so and and then once you have
the basics down you can look at some of
them the traces in the old pieces and
then what he's doing is he's Ari
recreating some of these axes and that
the call for the axes is mostly by
people who hue-hue logs for building
houses those are the guys who have the
money to buy axes and get them made just
exactly the way they want and so and
that's actually important distinction I
think we all are thinking of the Viking
TV show where the only axe as we see are
being wielded towards the other the
other bad Vikings or the English but the
one of the major uses of excess is
really as a building tool yeah I mean
that's probably 99% of the axes were
used on the farm to do farm chores or
build you know a new outhouse or
something whatever whatever they needed
they had to kind of kind of regional
specific ways of hewing and joining
timber and building structures out of it
and there's still people doing that now
yes right yeah yeah yeah
definitely I don't think too many new
buildings are built that way but
buildings that have rotted timber on
them or they sometimes I guess lift it
and make a duplicate flog and slip it in
and especially in the sills and the
foundations you know some of this stuff
rots but like I say there's there's
houses standing there that have been
there for five hundred years they don't
look like they need that much repair and
so it looks like a good investment you
know to keep if you do need to do the
work do it you know because it'll it'll
be there for centuries and so those guys
the guys who have the the contracts to
do this restoration work in a lot of
cases they'll have these suite axes like
this old axe maybe that works so well
but they know if they use it they're
gonna use it up so they they in a lot of
in many cases they'll pay a guy to make
the axe right you know and and reproduce
it and the amazing thing to me in
watching Matias work is he he'll make a
few measurements on an old axe go cut
off a piece of steel and he'll is like
his first one it's not the only one he's
made but without looking at any any
intermediate stages or whatever he was
able to knock that axe out which almost
just laid over the one he's copying
and the but we're also going to open
this up to check questions soon and
you're gonna be around too and I and I
hope walk around to some of these
stations where where you can explain
some of these objects in more detail but
where what is your what is your kind of
hope with where where to go with some of
this next is it really just to convey it
to the to another generation or is there
where's your who's your apprentice my
apprentice is the world now oh I I kind
of considered the way blacksmithing and
lilia most most trades have been handed
down or across or whatever over you know
thousands of years and basically you
know it there has been the master or
journeyman apprentice system where one
person teaches a few other in his life
and they you know they continue that
work and then you know as things move
along in the industrial era factories
wanted to make sure that there were
standards for production so they might
keep mid-stage pieces around and have
drawings and specifications for their
work and industrial economy and that
might need people who simply go to
school and learn this stuff but still
it's gonna generally amount to one
teacher and a dozen students or
something like that you know it's a it's
it's getting the word out in maybe more
effective way but I have kind of
realized that the best way to to do
maybe a lot of this would be to put the
knowledge online and I thought maybe the
best way to do it would be to Forge
things in stages to make the plastic
flow of the material obvious because it
is quite obvious if you can compare two
pieces that have only had 15 minutes of
work done between them you can see what
was done if you have only the finished
piece it's nearly impossible to tell how
it's done you can say in theory oh yeah
that's nice Oh meta crap but to do it is
is an extreme amount of work to
reproduce a piece yet if somebody does
it if they go to the work of making
stages then they can go and show people
these pieces and you moderately
experienced Smith could suddenly I think
make an axe you know maybe buy a second
or third try but it also occurred to me
in doing that that I was carrying a box
of 40 pounds of unique pieces which if I
had simply lost one would be a total
pain in the ass I'd have to make it over
again you know of course I have the
letter should be able to do it right
because I have of the previous pieces
but it would just be a terrific pain in
the ass and and there's no reason for it
to to be that dire so I just thought
well what if we just start scanning this
stuff the the the information conveyed
by any stage is simply its shape so the
easiest thing to get a 3d scan it would
be you know this chunk of iron it's flat
black it's relatively small and you know
it represents a very specific stage that
would be nice to remember for a long
time so basically a friend of mine at
our one of our California blacksmith
Oktoberfests last year had us he had
some sort of scanning software and was
using a digital camera to make 3d scans
of people and stuff and I said well
could you do a few of these for me
Whitney Potter so he he did three pieces
for me and sent me the 3d prints I
thought this is perfect it's like a it
could be downloaded from online it
weighs like two ounces not two pounds
and it's not you it's no longer unique
it could be printed out anywhere in the
world and it could represent a process
extremely well maybe better than
anything that you know not me you know
maybe one percent worse than having the
actual steel pieces but you know still
that the fact that it could be
downloaded a million times you know is
it's kind of awesome so and I did the
Facebook nerd friends in Scandinavia are
they
of the forging nerds I mean are they
were they using some of these objects
well no no yes as a matter of fact they
though I showed them this is like
plastic so you don't get it you don't
get it the next generation the academics
are kind of like not so interested in
smithing and the Smiths are not quite
know making the connection or they don't
really necessarily know where to get a
scan done but here you know in in you
know virtually in Silicon Valley as
would be the easiest thing to get done
and it seems like you know if somebody's
willing to collect the knowledge and
make the make the sequence that would be
relatively easy to to put out there
great so we'll open up for questions
we'll also just be around for quite a
bit this evening and then we're gonna
drink the stuff that Jim didn't make we
have yes we're gonna be all prepared
okay
yeah and it's 120 proof but yeah yes not
very well it's session is on samurai
swords yeah yeah I am I have not delved
into that really much at all I have a
little bit of literature which I hope to
read someday but you know I I think that
is probably some of the best work that's
that's ever been done in traditional
blades but it's not really what speaks
to me in terms of what I'll go out in
the shop and do it seems beyond me and I
am very attracted to the form change and
you know that the plastic development of
these types of things because it's a
forging challenge straight out whereas
the sword development is more just a
plain like skill it's yes see there's
also over-the-top like complex
and finally controlled and in the end
it's you can't use it for a lot and you
know I sort of like the connection to to
the woodwork I'm finding more and more
interest personally in the woodwork
that's done with these things too and
getting in touch with viewers who make
timber frame houses things yeah yeah
well I mean the first thing that strikes
me about them is that they really got
around and that that in itself is just
really interesting to me that they were
so expansive and so curious and I wanted
to trade and other things and you know
as soon as they were able to you know
they apparently just burst out of
Scandinavia and these beautiful boats
and went all over the place and
basically it was it's all due to their
their their skills with woodworking and
you know that was sort of catalyzed by
their knowledge of how to make great
axes and tools and their if they must
have been inventive and adaptive you
know to to come up with a lot of the
stuff that they did some of it might be
based on Roman fragmentary Roman
knowledge and so and you actually worked
a little bit or went to a site where
they're recreating some of these old
boats
yeah yeah they're building a replica of
a hundred foot long
probably some rating well it might be a
trade boat or something I'm not quite
sure Gokstad ship and they're doing it
straight up original there they're
getting oak logs from Denmark I believe
and they're simply splitting them they
it doesn't take a lot of tooling to
split an immense log if the grains you
know if it's been chosen for its
straight grain for shipbuilding
then basically they make a few cuts in
the front with an axe and then they get
little wedges in there and they just
start driving the wedges in and it
starts pops to the end of the log apart
and then they start driving them in the
length and all of a sudden the log just
pops into pieces
that's an extreme skill you know so that
doesn't go off or twist which will cause
you a lot of lumber loss yeah one of my
favorite stories about that kind of one
of those great long-term thinking
stories that kind of along the lines of
the oak beams of Oxford story that we
tell often is actually a vastly more
documented story that is from the
Norwegian Navy we're just you know in
the last 20 years the Norwegian Forester
sent a note to the Norwegian Navy saying
we have the masts that you planted 200
years ago for your for your ship so that
you know they had to plant them 200
years before they needed them of course
and so they in the 1800's they planted
masts for the Navy that they clearly are
going to need in a year 2000 so other
questions
[Music]
I would get questions so where do you
draw the line between traditional
non-traditional and what what aids the
process well Mike generally my goal is
to end up with a finished artifact that
reproduces the technical steps that the
originals probably used so the fact that
I'm welding a handle on to here is it
doesn't end up in the finished piece
it's a bit of a cheat but it gives me
extreme control over the piece and yet
it's it's a you know a bit of work that
I have to do every single time that yes
I should make the tongs every Smith
should make those tongs you know that
you just keep welding a handle on to it
for but it's not essential to the finish
it's not central to the finished piece
so I allow myself that and yet I do want
to I totally want to forge weld the
joints you know that's the absolute
requirement I think he also drives a
modern car to his shop to the Past
what's your intention is this about
discovery about archaeology like
hands-on archeology about the viking era
or is this more about like artisan
craftsmanship i guess i'm always about
the history or you about the future or
that or the present i I like to have a
time in my shop investigating
possibilities that that might have
possible techniques that might have been
used in the past to get stuff done
whenever possible I will gladly have
somebody just tell me how to do it and
then I'll I'll do that you know I enjoy
simply doing things the way they were
done like when I was a kid I was like
fascinated by Colonial Williamsburg
because they're like hardcore about just
doing everything the old way there I'm
not quite that hardcore if I can hey I
don't want to dress up and be I know I I
do want to get it done and go on to the
next thing I don't want it to be
hierarchical thing where I have to go
learn everything from some guy and it's
like I want to work through stuff and
get a basic familiarity with the
limitations and the discipline of the
material without you know taking twice
as long to do it and you know part of
the reason is I want to represent that
sense of this is doable to other people
you know I'm trying to open the doors
and make it accessible and then you can
also you can always regress the
technique you could get the clothes you
can sit on the ground with your aunt you
know your little anvil and you can make
this and once you know how to do the axe
the other part would be sort of in a way
easier you know the clothes so dressing
up in the front row
how much does the tiny anvil painting
handle about $100 yeah and modern
animals are just cast objects now
they're uh forage typically yeah no
nobody's forging them anymore yeah so
you're gonna go you want to go on eBay
and find one from at least a hundred
years ago and don't spend any more than
$100 write a question on how to set up
your space and I was actually struck
when we were at your space that you know
you have it set up obviously so you can
get the hot metal to the next thing to
the next thing to the next thing pretty
much by pivoting and nearly just a few
steps right right well that's a really
interesting point because when I went to
learn in Germany I was so shocked by the
disorganization and the mess shop that I
worked in that I spent about a week I'm
I think I think they told me I spent two
weeks just cleaning it up I wouldn't
even listen to what they wanted me to do
I just cleaned up so that's one aspect
of it the other is if you look at old
like illustrations of the trades in the
16th century a worker was depicted
sitting down not standing maybe the
Smiths you know who did big work where
were you know they obviously had to
stand and move around but like the sort
of white-collar work back then you know
Locke making those guys sat down they
had nice they had sat in front of a
window and they had all their tools
there so you know there's always an
impetus to have your work space set up
exactly for the job they might have been
more specialized in are not needed as
many spaces and tools as I do now to try
to do different things but it's kind of
all over the map over there if you're a
general job or you know you have a lot
of different tools just because you
don't know what's going to walk in the
door
and you sort of make an ad-hoc workspace
maybe and if you're more specialized
then you know like a machinist maybe you
know you just everything's laid out back
in those days they I think they worked
in the in very dark conditions mattias
the Swedish guy had a little traditional
smithy and there's like there was a flap
in the roof which led a shaft of rain
come in or whatever and a little door
and other than that it was like pretty
darn dark in there there was a light of
the fire and I found this kind of
atrocious conditions to work in it was
very traditional yeah I have to say your
shop is one of the nicer shops I've ever
been in certainly one that involves
forging yes so last question well to the
first point the the way that they formed
material avoided stretching like it
avoided stretching the material it
compressed it to get all the shape
change done and that can be a big
advantage if you're not too sure about
the quality of your material or if it
has a flaw in it which probably wouldn't
have been uncommon back then so they
were able to hammer it in different
directions and squeeze it basically into
a longer shape with special features the
only stretch that occurs is when they
fold it the outer outer surface
stretches but it's pretty thin and
pretty mild step there and then then
again they're there forging it back
together and compressing it so it's it's
a method that is sort of designed to
deal with fibrous material that might
otherwise want to fray a little bit and
if you drive a hole through a block
you're stretching everything around the
hole
and you might just break a semen in the
and the piece are trying to to form and
the other thing is I really doubt that
they have a steel back then that they
could simply keep hammering into a hot
piece of iron and without the end of the
tool simply you know heating up and just
bending or riveting into the hole
so you know they were doing pretty deep
they would have had to do very deep cuts
to get the shapes that they did in this
second the second question was yeah it's
a great one to end on which is are there
are there still innovations to be had in
fortune I don't know will ever know all
that they knew so I can't say we whether
we can innovate beyond what they've done
in in technical traditional stuff I
think you know with all of the hundreds
of thousands of Smith's that have
existed for several thousand years it
would it would be a hard to ever you
know figure out if somebody hadn't done
what you were proposing to do and that's
about all I could say about that I mean
it's kind of like bicycles every time
someone thinks they've invented
something you can pull out the old book
and go you know what actually that's and
they were under a lot more competitive
pressure back then you know do it well I
think it's important to remember that
that's at one point like making this
kind of object was the highest
technology of its day yeah and and these
were the you know these were the people
making the spaceships of their time
right now in the rocket scientists and
so it was theirs it was at one point
this was always the highest technology
yeah so thank you Jim for sharing
[Applause]
[Music]